[Musica]
Sono davvero contento di essere qui oggi
pensate che l'ultima volta che sono
salito su questo palco ero in prima
elementare quindi A dire il vero no
anche se è passato troppo tempo e in
quell'occasione per la classica recita
di fine anno avevo davvero un ruolo
chiave ed ero qui perché avevo un ruolo
di essere un albero sempreverde
esattamente come questo e sono contento
perché oggi non tocca a me come potete
immaginare
Ma a proposito di alberi vi siete mai
chiesti come facessero i nostri antenati
a capire se frutta e verdura fossero
commestibili
ad esempio con quella che noi oggi
chiamiamo pesca iniziavano a osservare
se queste si è mangiato dagli animali
nel caso la coglievano e la aprivano
metastavano la consistenza ne
osservavano il colore e ne annusavano il
profumo
e quindi come poteva essere questa pesca
o dura dei Calori vivaci dal profumo
pungente Forse era meglio lasciarla lì
oppure morbida dai colori tenui dal
profumo fruttato potrebbe non essere
male
a questo punto l'assaggiavano
e nel caso in cui questa
avesse un sapore gradevole non so questo
dove abbiamo comprato ma non lo ha né
iniziare a mangiare in quantità sperando
di poter ripeterlo l'operazione in
domani
Ma ora come fare a far sapere a quante
più persone possibili che questa cosa
questa pesca è commestibile
se pensiamo a tutte le scoperte che da
sempre hanno caratterizzato la vita
dell'uomo possiamo constatare come
questa vengono ad oggi come avvenivano
esattamente ai tempi dei nostri antenati
ovvero attraverso un approccio
esplorativo dove L'uomo entra in
contatto con una scoperta attraverso la
propria capacità di osservare l'utilizzo
dei cinque sensi e qualche intuizione
purtroppo non sempre fortunata
ma se da una parte il processo alla base
delle scoperte è rimasto sostanzialmente
invariato nel tempo ciò che invece è
mutato è la forma dell'informazione
ossia la sua rappresentazione
l'uomo Infatti spinto dalla necessità e
dalla volontà di diffondere le proprie
scoperte a via via modificata la
rappresentazione dell'informazione
stessa passando dal Passaparola ai
diagrammi alla scrittura e questa ha
portato così a un processo che ha
portato quindi a uniformare prima e
democratizzare poi la conoscenza
tutto ciò Ha determinato un'evoluzione
anche dell'approccio all'informazione
stessa pensiamo all'esempio di prima
Cioè per sapere se una pesca fosse
commestibile è necessario assaggiarla
provarla annusarla a quello che è un
approccio consultativo dove la stessa
informazione risiede Su un supporto
esterno come ad esempio un libro
Ed è proprio Gutenberg con l'invenzione
della stampa che ha sempre di più
portato alla conferma di questo
paradigma che via via si è consolidato
nel tempo con quelle che sono le
tecnologie che ci sono poi
consolidate negli anni successivi
pensiamo a internet con i computer che
poi sono diventati parte delle vite di
tutti i giorni
agli smartphone dove
questo ci ha permesso poi di avere un
accesso di informazioni giorno e notte
sempre a portata di mano
tutto corretto è bello No direte voi ma
come tutte le cose spesso c'è un'altra
faccia della medaglia
se provaste a digitare su Google la
parola pesca ciò che vi comparirebbe
esattamente questo
e c'è una frase che mi colpisce
particolarmente che dice a una drupa
rotondeggiante con una buccia pubescente
che non so voi ma a me non è che dia
grandi aspettative Cioè io non la mangio
quella roba ok E infatti sebbene il
fatto di addentare qualcosa di
pubescente possa dare fastidio ai più in
botanica al termine pubescenza indica
quella leggera peluria che ricopre gli
organi vegetali
questi In realtà sono un semplice
esempio per dimostrare come l'approccio
consultativo sebbene sia immediate ci
permetta di accedere a un'informazione
in modo istantaneo riporti solamente una
parte della rappresentazione
dell'informazione e quindi la sfida dei
giorni di oggi è proprio questo Cioè in
che modo possiamo ridare
all'informazione la rappresentazione che
si merita
viene enorme divario fra la grande
quantità di dati che ad oggi abbiamo a
disposizione e il mondo da cui questi ne
derivano questo perché i dati che ad
oggi consultiamo ogni giorno provengono
nella stragrande maggioranza dei casi
attraverso un dispositivo digitale Come
può essere uno smartphone piuttosto che
un tablet il mondo in cui viviamo
ovviamente è tridimensionale quindi vi è
un evidente divario da colmare fra
quello che ad oggi l'informazione è
disponibile e il luogo in cui queste
vengono applicate Ed è proprio qui che
la realtà aumentata ci viene d'aiuto
pensate che secondo statista fornitore
leader di mercato didatti di consumo
l'accesso È un'informazione che avviene
tramite un contenuto testuale determina
solamente il 20% della memorizzazione
della stessa Passate dopo due settimane
in caso di contenuto multimediale quindi
un'immagine piuttosto che un video Il
40%. e nel caso in cui lo stesso
contenuto venga fruita attraverso
un'esperienza immersiva e quindi in
realtà aumentata oltre l'ottanta per
cento
e Questo spiega perché la realtà
aumentata una tecnologia così potente
andando Infatti a unire il mondo fisico
con il mondo digitale e sovrapponendo
immagini audio e contenuti interattivi
nel mondo intorno a noi riduce lo sforzi
di dover collegare mentalmente il
contenuto al mondo che ci circonda a
vantaggio di quello che il carico
cognitivo
Infatti inconsciamente so che facciamo
tutti i giorni quando attingiamo delle
informazioni ciò che facciamo è quello
di andare a memorizzare quante più
informazioni possibili all'interno poi
del nostro cervello e successivamente
sfruttarle per prendere azioni quello è
appunto definito carico cognitivo a cui
si aggiunge un altro tema che è quello
della distanza cognitiva
poiché un'informazione che viene appunto
consultato attraverso un test per
esempio avrà una distanza cognitiva
Maggiore rispetto a un messaggio vocale
perché le parole devono essere le
lettere devono essere convertite in
parole Le parole a loro volta
interpretate
prendiamo però un esempio pratico della
vita di tutti i giorni immagino che
tutti abbiate utilizzato un navigatore
quindi tendenzialmente ciò che facciamo
è quello di andare a impostare la
destinazione di arrivo sul nostro
telefono e successivamente
utilizzare poi quel quell'informazione
via via per capire che azioni puoi
prendere Svolta a sinistra destra
proseguire dritto
e questo diciamo oltre a essere un
motivo per cui spesso poi sbagliamo
strada sta anche nel fatto che genera un
elevato carico cognitivo nel dover
prendere un'azione mentre si sta
guidando
Provate a immaginare quanto sarebbe più
facile se la stessa informazione fosse
disponibile in questo modo Quindi con
una freccia stampata sull'asfalto dove A
questo punto diciamo anche lo sforzo nel
dovere prendere quell'informazione e
tradurla nell'ambiente intorno a noi
sarebbe sicuramente più semplice
oppure un altro esempio
a tutti Sarà capitato di dover cambiare
l'arredo di casa ok tendenzialmente ciò
che facciamo è provare a prendere delle
strane misurazioni e immaginare come
quel tappeto quel divano possa stare
all'interno del nostro soggiorno di casa
ed oltre a essere c'è un motivo di
weekend Space nei centri commerciali
magari anche in città diverse per
provare ad avere l'ispirazione magica
e questo ovviamente genera una
difficoltà nel capire se quel prodotto
può fare al caso nostro
e in questo contesto la realtà aumentata
ci aiuta attraverso la possibilità di
poter scegliere il prodotto di
riferimento e posizionarlo di
conseguenza all'interno dell'ambiente in
cui ci troviamo esattamente in questo
modo
[Musica]
pensate che prima di salire sul palco mi
sono chiesto come sarebbe stato
raccontare a amici e colleghi
di essere il primo speaker nella storia
di Ted a portare una tigre sul palco
Ok siamo qui quindi immagino che vi
vediate
Ok
C'è mia nonna che ancora convinta che
abbia adottato una tigre in un bilocale
di 70 metri quasi a Milano
[Musica]
ok
tutto Questo spiega perché la realtà
aumentata una tecnologia così potente
Infatti andando ad aggiungere quelli che
sono come Abbiamo appunto appena visto
contenuti digitali interattivi
nell'ambiente intorno a noi riduce lo
sforzi di dover immaginare quello che è
un'informazione Una rappresentazione
della stessa in un ambiente fisico
e quindi per rispondere poi anche alla
domanda iniziale Ovvero come avrebbero
fatto i nostri antenati se
diciamo avessero dovuto rispondesse alla
domanda se quella pesca fosse davvero
commestibile ciò che gli sarebbe bastato
fare esattamente questo
[Musica]
per finire aggiungo che in realtà senza
andare indietro i tempi nostri antenati
mi chiedo perché è la stessa tecnologia
non fosse disponibile qualche anno fa
e magari le mie care maestre invece che
mettere a me a fare l'albero in
sceneggiatura avrebbero potuto mettere
in realtà aumentata
Grazie